so many great film roles to discuss I
want to move on to the Curious Case of
Benjamin Button what is your most fond
memory of that experience that was tough
actually it was really tough we were the
first crew to go in film to go into New
Orleans after Katrina and so it was a
quite a lawless environment and it was
quite a scary play there were six
shootings I think in the first few days
that we were there and it was quite
obviously my children were with me and
it was it was quite unsettling and
Fincher does you know oh he of the 197
takes you know you and it was a lot of
prosthetics so often you'd start at 4:00
in the morning and you think okay well a
regular human being would have you
finishing at 6:00 or 7:00 at night but
you just find yourself there some nights
at 11 still working you know felt like
you know the Witch of the West they're
melting but in kept shooting but it was
astonishing because if it was he is
meticulous but also so engaged as a
director and and he knew he was at the
beginning of you know that that digital
process and it was a one of them
strongest memories I have is getting
used to it so I'm going to some really
date myself now but getting used to the
the different rhythm that you one has
when one works with film literal film in
the camera where you'll do one maybe two
takes and you'll stop you're decompress
you'll reload you'll probably chat to
the focus puller you have a chat to the
director you dig and then you wind up
again and do another take whereas this
we would just go and go and go and go
and go and so it felt it I felt like a
quite quite cultish actually the
beginning of the process because it was
an entirely new way of working and so
it's perfect for him because you know he
often you know I think that the long
many most takes I did was probably about
36 but you know you you will go through
a dip where you know you'll all lose
your way but come back but you find a
different
type of rhythm and also watching him
really invent the way that you light on
digital because often what happens is um
you know I watched a I'm a popper tuckus
film cordless Emmys that based on The
Maids because I was about to do the
maids with the Sydney Theatre Company
with Isabella pair and I was in Berlin
and I thought great I finally got a copy
I'll put it on and I was so shocked
because it looked like someone's
terrible home video you know it's shot
on video and this exquisite beautifully
masterly lit film was was it just I
wasn't being able to see it in the right
way but Fincher knows how most people
are going to consume the work and so
he's lighting and shooting for the
correct medium so it was a real it was a
it was a very important and you know big
privilege to me to have that sort of
ability to be right there learning how
to work on digital
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]